[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there is only one war that matters and
it is here
[Music]
[Applause]
it's overwhelming but in the best
possible way a place where people can
really demonstrate their passion
[Music]
[Music]
see the joy brings so many people faces
it's amazing you know but they didn't
watch that they weren't fans we would
have nothing to do so it's our way of
kind of saying thank you if you ended up
on the Iron Throne both be the first law
you pass the women could be nice
how about a maester better clean out
their own stinking bed yep
there are one character boudoir us
hadn't been killed who would have been I
just really loved working with Jack
Gleeson so much that I have to say
Joffrey the show made by grown-ups for
grownups and we take chances this season
especially everyone's kind of
congregating to team up against the
oncoming threat you can feel the
momentum building lots of stuff coming
to a head alliances are being forged
alliances are being broken it's all
picking up it's only going to get bigger
and better
you
you